I just saw this thing in USA today
celebrating the 100th anniversary of a
woman's right to vote it says when when
women when women won the right to vote
in 1920 the world changed please join us
a today in commemorating this milestone
by nominating outstanding American women
who inspire you you can submit your
nominations here then there's a link and
I've seen a lot of media articles about
the 100 anniversary of a woman's right
to vote and we'll be seeing many more
I'm sure in the lead-up to August which
will be the official 100 anniversary of
when the the 19th amendment was ratified
but here's a problem this is this is my
point and as we see this more and more
and you know what I'm gonna say at this
point you watch this show you know what
I'm gonna say you know what point I'm
about to make here but I have to say it
women's right to vote what are women
what does that mean what do you mean
women won the right to vote what what is
that
what do you mean by that I mean I I know
what it what that tradition
traditionally means I know what it means
scientifically but according to
left-wing gender Theory there's no such
thing as a woman really so how can you
celebrate it in fact according to
left-wing gender Theory women had been
voting all along women didn't win the
right to vote in 1920 they had been
voting all along because a lot of males
are actually women so and a lot of men
in fact were prevented from voting
because a lot of women are men so
women's suffrage is not really women's
suffrage mostly because women don't
exist as their own distinct category it
turns out women's rights in general
really are men's rights and men's rights
are women's rights and none of this
means anything this is the implication
of left-wing gender theory I'm afraid to
say and I just I have to point that out
and I'm gonna continue pointing that out
as this as we as the the celebrations
continue it just it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't make it the most you could
say is that it wasn't that women won the
right to vote in 1920 it was a certain
body part did so those who happen to
as traditionally female reproductive
organs won the right to vote but those
people aren't necessarily women they
could they're also men or they could be
any of the other 172 genders so that's
if we want to be specific that's what
we're really talking about now
all right well as as you know switching
gears here four days after Trump ordered
the strike on the global mass killer
Qasem Soleimani Democrats in the media
have been heaping praise and adulation
on the dead terrorists as we've talked
about on this show and chronicled while
fretting that the President had
inaugurated World War three and perhaps
fretting is not the right word maybe
hoping might be more apt and then Iran
began launching missiles at our bases in
Iraq and at that point these same people
assured us that the dreaded or perhaps
longed-for moment had finally arrived it
was World War three but then that attack
claimed no American casualties caused
little damage and was revealed to be
nothing but a symbolic face-saving
measure by Iran and when that happened
we were told by the left that in fact in
the words of code pink the Iranians were
being quote the adults in the room the
but but the benevolent Iranians decided
to spare us the destruction and death
that they could have that they could
have rained down upon us at every step
of course no credit whatsoever was given
to Donald Trump or the American military
they were painted as reckless bumblers
at best
to paraphrase democratic representative
joyce Bedi who said there was it was it
was reckless or more nefarious assassins
at worse
according to Democratic Representative
Pramila jayapala who called Donald Trump
an assassin says it was an assassination
every step of the way Democrats in
Congress and their mouthpieces in the
media were more than willing to
propagandize on behalf of the Iranian
government if it gave them an
opportunity to land a blow against Trump
as always opposed Trump at all costs is
the motto even if that means openly
siding with America's sworn enemies now
this whole performance as we have
discussed over the past week has been
disgraceful enough enough but it hardly
even
prepares us for the developments
yesterday now it appears that Iran
accidentally shot down that Ukrainian
passenger plane which is not a surprise
when we found out that a Ukrainian
passenger jet crashed taking off from
Tehran on the same night that that Iran
was sending this barrage of missiles and
Iran of course is still claiming it was
engine failure but now we're hearing
from sources in the United States that
know they they that they shot down one
of the planes probably accidentally but
of course that's what it was because by
the way you know to have to have dual
engine failure in a passenger jet
minutes after takeoff or at any time
during the flight and for that to crash
the plane that is almost unheard not
completely unheard of but it almost
never happens
extremely rare but obviously that wasn't
that that's clearly wasn't the case here
now this is a terrible tragedy and an
additional moral outrage brought about
by the Iranian regime's disregard for
human life at least that's how people
with common sense and a love for America
will see it but Democrats in the media
are not burdened by either of those
things they love for America or common
sense so shockingly well it should be
shocking anyway but it's not they have
placed the blame for Iran shooting down
a passenger jet on the United States and
Donald Trump Democratic presidential
candidate Pete Budaj
declined to condemn Iran for doing this
and instead said that it was a quote
unnecessary and unwanted military
tit-for-tat that caused the downing of
the jet democratic representative Jackie
Speier called the tragedy collateral
damage from the actions that have been
taken in a provocative way by the
president United States then various
members of the media were online
yesterday calling it crossfire it was a
the jet was caught in the crossfire this
was you know very conspicuous because
you
members of the media online on social
media on Twitter using this phrase
caught in the crossfire all almost
simultaneously the other as if as if a
memo went out which I wouldn't be
surprised if it really did there was an
actual memo they all started saying oh
the jet was caught in the crossfire this
was in the you the Canadian media
personalities and there were a number of
Canadians who were who were killed in
the plane crash and Canadian media
personalities were also putting the
blame on Donald Trump Seth Abramson a
media guy and just an all-around hack
never never willing to lose a who's the
biggest hack contest he pointed the
finger at Donald Trump and Sean Hannity
a Berman's Abramson suggested that the
Iranian government may have been spooked
by what Sean Hannity was saying on the
night of the of the missile attack and
then in a panic shot down a plane I mean
now how does that work exactly I don't
know how can we suggest that that what a
what a cable news host was saying in
America could somehow cause a plane to
be shot down well that's what he would
but that's that's his theory this
obviously is all nonsense
there was no crossfire because the
United States wasn't returning fire
there was no crossfire Trump has
expressly expressly declined to
participate in a tit-for-tat as buddha'
judge called it Trump ordered the strike
on soleimani because he was a dangerous
terrorist who had killed many Americans
and had just days earlier stage an
assault on our embassy the justified and
lawful killing of a war criminal in a
war zone in Iraq on January 3rd clearly
cannot cause a plane to be shot down in
Iran on January 8th if Iran is to
incompetent or to reckless to launch
missiles without running them into
passenger airlines by mistake or on
purpose the fault lies completely and
totally with them obviously keep in mind
the missile strike was nothing but a
face-saving measure in the first place
so array
and then blew up 176 civilians in an
effort to soothe their bruised ego which
is only a further indictment of them our
enemy not us of course I shouldn't need
to explain this and I don't the media
understands it so do the Democrats but
they are both possessed of this
pathological need to hate Trump and
blame America at all costs under all
circumstances and normally with this
kind of stuff we can we can shrug it off
but I don't think we can shrug this off
because they're providing PR cover to a
foreign enemy that has murdered an
American attacked our embassy and now
blown up a commercial aircraft all in
the span of a month and these people the
Democrats in the media are giving them
cover this is despicable bordering on
treasonous that word treasonous traitor
has been logged by the left at Donald
Trump quite a lot but what do you call
it when you've got American politicians
American officials American media
members who in this in this court or
running to the defense of our enemies an
enemy who has been staging attacks
against us over the last month they are
aiding and abetting the enemy what do
you call that and this further
demonstrates why Democrats can never be
given control of the government because
they don't have the interests of
Americans at heart they don't love our
country and we can't trust them one
other quick thought about this that you
know Democrats have been very upset that
they're still upset that Trump didn't
consult with them before doing the
strike against allamani and they want to
make sure that in the future they're
consulted well this proves exactly why
Trump can't consult them in a perfect
world I would
that the president should consult with
Congress there should be that sort of
check in place before something like
this but these are not normal
circumstances he can't tell them because
they'll sabotage it it's very clear from
this they don't want him to have a
victory they don't really want America
and have a victory they have no problem
taking Iran's side do you think these
people are above sabotaging it leaking
it ahead of time to try to or were
somebody who knows what they would do
with the information you just can't
trust them we can't trust them Trump of
course can't trust them that's the
situation we're in them yeah I don't say
that lightly because it's a it's a it's
a horrible thing to think but the fact
is you had an entire political party now
on on the national level on the federal
level that cannot be trusted they they
we as Americans can't trust them so I
would hope that in the future if there's
anything like this that comes up again I
would hope that Trump does not consult
them all right now before we move on a
quick word from noon you know getting in
shape doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weigh weight or a
magic number on the scale I think
sometimes when you get too obsessed with
that element of it and you get these
arbitrary numbers in place I want to I
want to lose X amount of weight it can
become distracting sometimes it's
discouraging it's really about building
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself if fitting into that
favorite pair of jeans is your golden
great but there are many reasons why you
might want to practice self-care and
every person is different and for me the
reason that I use them it's all it's all
about simply getting healthier I think
the most important thing before you get
into how you look and all of that the
most important thing is to be healthier
now I don't have to lose a bunch of
weight but I did get into a habit of
eating unhealthy and just not not living
the kind of healthy lifestyle that I
wanted to live and you don't feel right
it's just it's that's that's that's the
issue I tell you what else it helps me
with is keeping track of my diet
you sort of organized in my attempt to
cultivate these healthy habits because
that's being organized cultivating good
habits that's one area where I struggle
with think a lot I think a lot of people
struggle with that and that's what Noom
is all about Noom is the habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses based in
psychology new teaches you why you do
the things you do it empowers you with
the tools you need to break bad habits
and replace them with better ones it's
not about food being good or bad or off
limits instead Noom teaches moderation
and that can be used in conjunction with
many preexisting popular diets if that's
what you want to do so you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon n-o-o-o m.com slash Walsh
what do you have to lose visit new mom
slash walls to start your trial today
that's n-o-o-o m.com slash Walsh well a
report in The Daily wire says in the
latest development prosecutors on
Thursday told a judge overseeing the
trial of Epstein's former cellmate
accused murderer Nicholas Tartaglia
owning that surveillance footage of the
hallway during Epstein's failed alleged
suicide attempt no longer exists because
of quote technical errors according to
the Associated Press
so the footage is it doesn't exist
tender Blair's perfectly fine perfectly
normal perfectly fine nothing to see
here no conspiracy that's all don't be a
conspiracy theorist this is all totally
normal stuff speaking of totally normal
here's some video footage that's gone
viral online over the last few days and
I want to show this to you what you're
about to see you're pretty upsetting
what you're gonna see here is a video of
animal rights activist throwing a
homeless man to the ground and stealing
his dog they're doing this to quote save
the dog from the horrors of homelessness
and and here's how that worked out watch
this
[Music]
now it turns out that this footage is
from a few years ago and just now going
viral for whatever reason
fortunately the dog just to give you the
the happy ending the the dog was
returned to the owner eventually and
those scumbags were arrested thank God
though I don't think that they actually
spent any time in jail but I wanted to
show this because to me it is it's a
perfect morbidly perfect tragically
perfect encapsulation of modern culture
isn't it save the dog leave the human
lying in the street that's that's I
cannot think of a better I could if you
wanted to I could think of a better ten
second clip of video that would that
would encapsulate and illustrate modern
culture than that
she's yanking the dog out of the hand of
a homeless man leaving him lying there
and and going off to save the dog now
some people who've defended the animal
rights thugs have said that well look
the man was not in a position to care
for the dog so this this was necessary
we had to do it for the dog okay but
what about the man what about the actual
human you've taken what is probably the
only companion that he has the only joy
he has in life and you've taken it for
him somebody online said that the dog
was his psychological lifeline which I
thought was a great way of putting it
and you're taking that lifeline away
from him that's it to be homeless
aasaiya from the physical strains of
being exposed to the elements not having
food and all those all those very
necessary things you don't have aside
from that the I think what what did the
worst thing about it is the dehumanizing
effect of feeling alone feeling like
nobody cares feeling alienated
ostracized reject biases is rejected by
society and not having companionship and
so I think especially for a homeless man
to have a dog to have that companion
it's very meaningful you you come and
rip literally rip that away from him do
you think about what that would do
psychologically and emotionally to a man
in that position now if you're concerned
about the dog not living in the right
conditions why not find the dog and the
man a place to live if you're that
concerned about it why not prioritize
his welfare but we live in a culture
where animal life is often prioritized
over human life and animals tend to
engender more sympathy more compassion
than humans do it's it's true when you
think about it I think about how people
would react if you're walking down the
street downtown and you see a homeless
dog by the sitting off on the side of
the sidewalk by itself
shivering hungry cold now of course
there are plenty of dogs in that
situation but but that's my point
normally those dogs when they're found
they get cared for and adopted because
people when they see a dog suffering
they react viscerally to it it's it's
it's it seems instinctive yet when we
see humans lying in the street we're
more able to step over them and ignore
them I think that's that's the honest
reality of it a lot of people you're
walking down the street you see a human
being lying on the sidewalk verse you
see a golden retriever lying alone on
the sidewalk shivering for a lot of
people the golden retriever is just
we're gonna be more sympathetic that's
good that's gonna make you stop and go
oh my gosh look at this beautiful dog
now it's true that with a dog you can
take a dog to an animal shelter and and
it's not always of course that easy with
it with a human being there are homeless
shelters but if the human doesn't want
to go there you can't sort of scoop them
up and take them the way that you could
with a dog so it's not always as simple
as that but still my contention is that
people these days in this culture many
people sympathize more with dogs and
humans much of the time now I've been
talking about this for a long time I
believe that that's the case
and I know it's the case but because
people admit it people are pretty direct
about it and unapologetic people admit
in fact they're proud it seems like you
hear people say things like dogs are
better than people you hear this a lot
people say this all the time or or my
personal favorite we don't deserve dogs
that sort of thing
we don't deserve dogs that to me is is
nails on a chalkboard I I cannot stand
that it is so grating to hear people we
don't deserve dogs what kind we don't
deserve them what do you do your what
think of all the things you do for your
dog you feed it you take it outside you
clean up its poop you do everything for
your dog you wait on your dog hand and
foot and you're really sitting there's
like I don't deserve you you're you're
you're outside cleaning up your dogs
crap and you're thinking I don't deserve
this now I would be thinking that maybe
in a different but in a different way I
don't deserve this
that's maybe how I would think it but
but you it's how I don't do this is such
a blessing such a blessing oh my
goodness
much of the time I would say it's sort
of the other way around I think dogs
don't deserve the way that we treat them
in the sense that we they get pampered
in a way that no other animal does so
maybe they don't deserve all that now if
you want to talk about we don't deserve
you know how about and this is my point
and there's nothing wrong with loving
dogs okay people get upset every time I
talk about this people get upset I'm
simply saying think we should have their
things should be proportional and there
is a disproportionate focus and love of
dogs at the expense of and priori
ties over people and that's a problem
people do this with their own with their
own children you know you hear people
talk about their dog the people have
some people have dogs and kids and talk
about their dog as if it's a just a
second child or a third child so if you
want to talk about we don't deserve I
think saying something like we don't
deserve the love of a child now that
yeah that I can relate to I've often
felt that way about my children I've who
are who just because young children are
so loving so naturally forgiving they
look up to you they adore you they want
to they want to be around you and it's
it's not as though okay they're not
animals so it's not it's it's actually
not as though they don't recognize your
flaws or anything like that they in fact
I think with with children they do
recognize the flaws but they're they're
naturally forgiving of them and parents
we've experienced this like recent
example for me there's so many examples
I could point to but recently you know
it's at the end of the day I mean I've
had a bad day I'm in a bad mood I have a
short temper and and you know and as
parents we that's how we are sometimes
you're just a little bit of a short fuse
not proud of it and at the other day my
kids are in bed and I'm you know I'm
feeling guilty that I've squandered this
time with them at the end of the day by
just being in a bad mood so I go up to
see if they're still awake my daughter's
awake she she she's you know it's an
hour after bedtime she's been upstairs
she hands me a picture she's been
working on and she said she made me this
picture it's a gift for me because she
could tell I was having a bad day and
she wanted to cheer me up and it was a
picture of me and her fishing and I
could tell that she'd been working on it
for an hour now that's the kind of thing
as a parent that it just destroys you
you're just you're like it's it's a this
mix of of joy and pride but also guilt
and pain because you think oh my gosh
what are this I'm so it's a one hand
thank you for this that's amazing thank
you
on the other hand and now I feel like it
even bigger piece of crap so I that's as
a parent I can relate to that feeling
when you when you compare this pure love
of a child with the selfishness of
adults right and the and you know adults
can be petty selfish malicious you just
don't you don't see that in young
children but I can't relate to that in
relation to a dog you know I the idea
that a dog could bring that same feeling
out of you dogs are not capable of
loving the way that humans do ok a dog
is yeah the dog might have some capacity
for comforting some capacity for that
sort of thing which is why I'm saying
stealing that dog from the homeless man
was such a horrible thing horrible for
the person because I'm focused on the
person the human horrible to him so dogs
do have that capacity but not nearly to
the same extent that human beings do the
children do and I've had pets and I've
had and I have kids and and the
difference is extremely obvious to me
and if it isn't to you then I think your
mind is kind of warped I think you have
a problem I don't even mean that as an
insult it's just it there is an issue
there by the way this is not something
we can just chalk up to the human
condition it's not like it's natural and
instinctive for people to worship dogs
this way because you go to so many other
places in the world so many other
cultures they don't have this this is
kind of a distinct Western thing where
we have put dogs on this pedestal and
and household pets in general I think in
other parts of the world you'll find
they have respect for animals they
believe just like we do we should treat
animals with dignity and I believe that
too but they still recognize that
animals are animals they're not people
it's really in Western culture that
we've elevated animals above people in
so many ways well Western cultures and
pagan cultures that literally worship
animals so
you find that continuity there which is
very disturbing and it's not just about
attitudes either it's about the law I
mean as we know every animal in
existence has more legal protection
according to our law code than babies in
the womb do because babies in the womb
have essentially zero legal protections
any animal every dog has more protection
than than human beings so this is not
it's not this is not an exaggeration
it's it's it's not only about our
attitudes it's also about our how our
laws are set up it is codified into law
that animals are worth more have more
worth more value more dignity than
babies in the womb because babies in the
womb according to the law have a zero
worth and zero value and this obviously
is not a coincidence it's not a
coincidence that so many people now have
begun to see dogs as being better than
or above people well at the same time
our law has actually codified that
that's not a coincidence and you see how
law can affect people's attitudes and
their beliefs and the way they see the
world politics are down stream of
cultures but sometimes it's the other
way around sometimes it's a little bit
of both
so let's could love our dogs we can love
our pets that's fine but we should
always and every time in every
circumstance we should be putting people
above animals and their needs and and
you know what's best for them comes
first so doe so animals should be
subordinated the needs of animals should
be subordinated to the needs of people
not the kind of thing that anyone should
need to actually argue for or explain
but that's where we are all right let's
go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from redacted dear supreme
dictator overall
thank you for so accurately pointing out
in your supreme wisdom that the road by
Cormac McCarthy is the best novel of the
21st century so far I wholeheartedly
agree and it's my all-time favorite
novel I first read it as a 16 year old
and thought I liked it because it was a
nuclear apocalypse book I'm reading it
again after discovering that my wife is
pregnant and it turns out I love this
book because it's about fatherhood my
question is what are your reasons why
it's the best novel for 21st century
why do you personally love it why did it
resonate with so many people as to win a
Pulitzer Pulitzer as always thank you
for your wit your emergently your
curmudgeonly charm and your willingness
to talk about matters people actually
care about like abortion and family
values rather than the same old boring
political prattle yeah I think that
where were even talking about this oh
yeah I sorry I put up I asked I posed
the question on Twitter a couple days
ago what do you think is the best novel
of the 21st century so far I'll be
interested to hear your responses to
that part of the reason I asked the
question actually it sort of selfishly
self-interested ly I was looking for
suggestions of recent novels because
part of the thing is yeah I I think the
road is my favorite novel that I've read
that was written in the 21st century I
also haven't read that many novels that
were written in the 21st set
I've read a lot of books of the 21st
century but many of most of them at
least the the fiction were written
before many of them centuries before so
I am interested in reading more recent
work recent fiction novels of the ones I
have read though the road was my
favorite and for the reasons that for
the reason that redacted that you
mentioned it because of this story of
fatherhood in this bond of this father
between the father and the son I have an
interesting relationship with this book
because I first picked it up maybe six
seven years ago at a bookstore and I
hated it I read maybe 15 pages up 15 20
pages i sat there and read it and I
thought it was terrible I was such as I
didn't like it I thought it was really
really bad
and I put it down and then a couple
years ago for some reason I was
motivated to pick it up again and I my
reaction couldn't it could not have been
any different was a total 180 in terms
of my perception of the book and I found
it to be really powerful and moving I
think I read the whole thing maybe not
in one night but in two nights I just I
blew through it and I think a lot of it
was a big difference
seven years ago I didn't have any kids
two years ago I had three and two sons
and so of course you start once your
once your place in life changes I think
the way that you interact with and
respond to works of fiction and art can
obviously change dramatically and that
was the case here I'd say I liked that
that the story revolves around this
father desperately trying to protect his
son at all costs but what I liked about
is he wasn't just trying to protect his
son's physical body he wasn't just
trying to keep him physically safe
although that was a big part of it
obviously living in a post-apocalyptic
wasteland with cannibals with cannibal
gangs roaming the countryside so a lot
of it is physical safety but a big theme
in the book they always talk about the
fire keeping the fire alive where the
man and the boy who aren't given names
the characters aren't given names in the
book but this is something they say to
each other about keeping the fire alive
within them what is the fire that's the
fire of goodness and so the father is
also very concerned in this oblique
seemingly hopeless environment where
people have been reduced to animals
literally eating each other one of his
main concerns is not only keeping his
son alive but protecting his goodness
and his dignity and I found that to be I
mean you couldn't find a theme for a
book that would resonate more with me
than that and so and I also thought it
was just really well well written Cormac
McCarthy's style of writing is not for
everybody takes some getting used to I
think when I first picked it up six
seven years ago that was part of what
jarred me it was the first McCarthy book
I'd read or tried to read and I found
the style hard too hard to stomach but
now I kind of appreciate it okay this is
from Saul or our soul much rather pounds
that says Matt absolutely love your show
thanks for what you do you've often
talked on your show about proofs of
God's existence I find these segments
fascinating but recently I've been
beginning to think that the best the
most important proof of God's existence
is the inner experience we all have of
him knowledge of God is innate do you
think that's something that should be
used more in an apologetic context no I
don't I don't maybe that'll surprise you
for me to say that but I don't think
it's a good apologetic argument at all
actually I've seen really smart people
use this argument William Lane Craig
uses it in his debates of he offers like
six or seven proofs of God's existence
and this is the last one that he always
goes to and it's okay because his others
are really solid but I always cringe a
little bit when he gets to the inner
experience the inner testimony of the
Holy Spirit as as a proof of God to an
atheist I think it's not effective and
I'll give you three reasons why number
one in order to use this again we're
talking about this is how you're talking
about apologetics not not as a
devotional thing so apologetic is
defending the faith to someone outside
of the faith not just defending it but
most of time trying to convince them to
be open to your arguments and to you
know the worldview that you're
presenting and so that's what we're
talking about now if we're talking about
in a devotional context there should be
a difference between I've read a lot of
apologetic books I've read a lot of
devotional books devotional books are
for Christians they're by Christians and
for Christians and it's all about
strengthening your faith apologetics
that's not what apologetic is
apologetics are supposed to be it does
have the effect of strengthen your faith
but that's not the primary goal of the
primary goal is to defend the faith from
challenges from the outside okay so in
that context as apologetic
I don't like it because number one you
would need to prove okay to use this in
an argument in a debate you would need
to prove that your inner conviction of
God's existence he's actually innate and
not merely the product of the fact that
you were raised to believe this or that
you were raised in a culture where lots
of people believe it and thus
conditioned that way now this is gonna
be easier maybe for you to do if you are
a convert from atheism so if you were
raised an atheist and then converted to
Christianity then maybe you could talk
about how you had this innate knowledge
your whole life and finally grew to
accept it so maybe I'll make an
exception in that case although it still
doesn't work for reasons I'll get to in
a second but if you were raised a
Christian in a Christian household born
into a Christian household told from the
earliest age that there is a God and now
you're saying that the knowledge is
innate well you see how that's gonna be
difficult to prove because your
Challenger your interlocutor can can
simply say well what do you mean how do
you know it's this is that you wouldn't
hold this literally since you emerge
from the womb and that's why you believe
it I mean how can you distinguish
between something you believe because
you've always been told it and something
you believe because it's just in your
head apart from what you've been told
it's very hard to do and it's it's it's
it's impossible to prove okay that's the
first one number two there's the problem
of the plurality of religion and this is
when you when when someone brings up the
innate knowledge of God in your argument
this is always gonna be the atheist for
my experience this is the Atheist first
move per least second move or they're
gonna say they're gonna bring up the
plurality of religion and point out that
there are seven billion people on earth
and most of them are not Christian
most of them claim that their innate
knowledge points to something else
entirely so how do you how do you know
that your innate knowledge is correct
and their instead of instead of theirs
how do we know that their innate
knowledge isn't a Muslim who says that
he has an eighth knowledge of Allah and
well how do you know that maybe he's
right and you're wrong
right that's that's the point that's
gonna be that's gonna be made number
three if you're saying that knowledge of
God is universally innate and you're
talking to an atheist who says he has no
such innate knowledge then you're in the
position of trying to tell the atheist
what he himself is thinking and putting
yourself as the higher authority on that
subject and that's a disaster a debate
that's disastrous when you get into
debating what your what the other person
is thinking you already lose because you
have zero evidence for what they're
thinking and they have 100% of the
evidence they are in that room you know
there's two of you debating there is one
person physically present that room who
is a 100% authority on what they are
thinking is and that is that person you
are a zero percent authority on that
subject and I've seen this this is one
of my problems with presuppositional
apologetics I've seen this in debates
where somebody tries to go the
presuppositional route and they end up
and they end up having this argument
where the atheist says well you know I
don't have this innate knowledge and and
the presuppositional said oh yes you do
now you do though I'm telling you what
you think you're not gonna win you
cannot win that argument
it may be convincing to you it may make
you feel better but it's not going to be
convincing to the atheist and anyone
else who witnesses the argument is going
to be very put off by your style of
argumentation and they're gonna think oh
these people got nothing so what you're
left arguing is that it's an innate
knowledge that you also coincidentally
had instilled in you from birth and that
for whatever reason leads people to
different conclusions about spirituality
and that the atheists are speaking to
really knows really has this innate
knowledge even if he doesn't know that
he has it so you view it it's it's a
it's not a strong argument from the
outside now am i saying that that
knowledge of God is not innate no I'm
not saying that but you asked me about
using it apologetically in an argument
with an atheist and I'm telling you how
it will come across if you try to do
that so what I'm and I think we need to
do this as Christians we don't do it
enough I think
where we take a step back and look at
this objectively and and look at it you
know how try to imagine how somebody
will see these arguments if they don't
share our belief system you to be an
effective debater or to present
effective arguments you have to be able
to do that so in my view the evidentiary
arguments are much stronger arguments
that point to or point out point to the
objective facts in the world facts that
as a starting point you can both agree
on starting with the existence of the
world itself so fine-tuning first cause
those things so your starting point
there is the world exists here are some
basic facts we know about it and some
some just physical facts and that's your
starting point and now you're in the
realm of arguing over objective facts
external facts you're not trying to
argue over what's going on inside that
other person's head so I think now
you're on strong footing then you get
into the origin of life the origin of
consciousness I have come to see as one
of the if not the strongest argument for
God even even more so than the origin of
the universe I think the origin of
consciousness there's an even stronger
proof I think all these are gonna give
you a much much stronger foothold in a
debate with an atheist then getting into
in a you know your your your personal
internal experience which has which has
a lot of evidence
cheri value for you and for me
personally my own in a you know internal
experience has a lot of imita
evidentiary value value for me but it
has zero evidentiary value for anyone
else and I have to acknowledge that and
realize that and proceed accordingly
okay this is from Tony says hello great
one I'm probably late to the party but
have you seen that Justin Trudeau has a
beard I'm in shock how could a man who
had Melania and Ivanka Trump staring
intently at his beautiful baby face grow
a beard I'm dumbstruck maybe he did it
as a way to just make his face appear a
bit darker we all know he has a weird
fetish for that kind of thing so does
this make you like him more or less now
that he's a beard bro do you feel like
kindred spirit with the Canadian Prime
Minister I'd love to hear your thoughts
in the biggest story of the week well
Tony I'm a firm believer in celebrating
all beards all facial hair and when it
comes to facial hair
I believe in tolerance inclusivity and I
invite and welcome anyone into the beard
club okay I'm not gonna get into you're
not a real true beardsman okay I don't
get into that a lot a lot of beardsman
they do and by the way that's what we
call ourselves according to me a lot of
beards men that's what they'll get into
that they'll get it so no he's not real
he's not part of the community I don't
believe in that I think if you but if
you grow the beard you're in the
community and now we do have that bond
we do have that Brotherhood doesn't mean
I agree with everything I don't have to
agree with everything you say and
everything you do but and the Halloween
costumes you wear in Justin Trudeau's
case but he's in the community now and I
will defend his beard to the death if I
have to
speaking of beards another beard related
question from Don says Matt what kind of
dye do you use for your beard okay I
wanted to answer this because we're
talking about beard discrimination and
some but I get this email you have no
idea how often I get this from people
asking me if I die my beard and I want
to say right now this is a vicious rumor
that's been circulating despite my
attempts to debunk it I do not die my
beard never have never would in fact it
pains me when people bring us up because
I'm actually I am I am developing a
little bit of gray in my beard a little
bit of dignified great I've been wet
I've been waiting since I was like 17 to
grow some gray in my beard okay
I've been an old soul my whole life may
not surprise you learn so now that I'm
finally getting a little bit of gray I'm
I'm excited about that and now I've got
all these people apparently I guess it
doesn't come through on camera you can't
see it if anything I would die my grade
up to put great to dye my beard to put
gray into it that's what I would do
dyeing your beard is crazy that now that
is offensive I think to the bearded
community because you should accept and
love your beard whatever color it comes
in and if you're getting grey in the
beard that's why why try to hide from
that now you could just start you know
you could start developing that Civil
War general kind of look who doesn't
want that so no I I don't dye my beard
and never would
how dare how dare all of you um let's
see I guess we'll leave it there no no
better topic to leave it on than beards
and I hope you guys have a great weekend
enjoy football go Ravens
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there